Hey,
what's going on is bill borough and it's
the Monday morning podcast from Monday,
April 28th, 2014 what's
going on? How, why, yeah,
I am recording this and, uh, I'm
actually, according to Sunday night,
I just finished doing my
show here in Albany, um,
at this beautiful theater. I don't
even fucking know the name of. Well,
look at that. Would you look at
that? And you're probably like,
why bill you arrogant ass?
Everybody came down to the fucking show.
You don't even know the name of the
place. Well, the reason for that is, is a,
I've been on vacation at a,
I felt like I was shaking rust off this
weekend. I had good shows and everything,
but I was more trying to
remember the order of things,
how I kinda did shit and what
connected to what. And uh,
whenever I do that,
I'm in my head too much and then I don't,
it doesn't flow as well. Um, you know,
only I noticed, but I
noticed so, uh, either way,
I want to thank everybody who came
out in Burlington, Vermont, um,
people who came out in Portland, Maine
and people came out here and, uh, Albany,
New York. It was great to come
back to this part of the country.
I did a lot of my early stand up,
especially up in Maine and he used to do
all the Bob Miley gigs up there at the
old comedy connection up there.
He used to do and um,
I didn't do too much shit in
Vermont. You know, Vermont is a, uh,
I dunno, that's like, it was
just a little, I was south
of Boston, so, you know,
you drove up 93, a route three,
you fucking won in New Hampshire.
Then he shot right into me.
And that was basically at
that little corner of it that,
that I, I went to. And um,
so this time when I came
back from Burlington, Vermont
to Portland, I could've,
I could've driven the fast way,
but I decided to go the scenic route.
I'm going to go, the CD crew can
see what the country looks like.
And I fucking went there and
it was amazing to look at.
But all I kept getting stuck behind people
and like mini vans or trucks and I'm
driving like a psycho.
And after a while there's only so many
furniture stores and Barnes and old
places with signs that you can look at
before you want to get the fuck out of
there. But, um, we had a
great time or for a month,
I didn't realize they had the
heroin problem. They did. You know,
I didn't bring it up during the
show because it was so not funny.
But Jesus Christ a fuck is their heroin.
Like that level of a problem in Vermont.
Vermont is like one of those states where,
you know,
you finally knock up your woman,
you know, like, you know what,
why don't we give this kid
a great childhood and where
should we move this kid
where no one can hurt him and he can
fucking run around with horses and all of
that Shit. Right. And, uh,
we know Vermont's one of those places.
Well that's right.
They had it in rolling stone.
The new face of heroin,
the explosion of drugs like
Oxycontin has given way to heroin.
The heroin epidemic ravaging the
least likely corners of America.
Jesus Christ
like Vermont. What does it say?
How do you pronounce B U, c. O. L,
I. C. B, U. C o. L, I. C,
Bucolic Bu Cocky Vermont,
which has just woken up to a
full blown crisis. You know,
ever since aids came out, not a lot
of people say full blown anymore.
So I want to give, I want to give
rolling stone a good nod there.
You know I was talking
to you about a while ago.
I was looking at theaters to do a new
special in an inside on old theaters.
The only time you used the word ornate
and another example is full blown,
full blown is only used with aids.
I mean,
what did they say?
I'm trying to think of pre aids.
So I fucking remember with full blown,
we've got a full blown epidemic.
I'll tell you, last night I went to the
bathroom after that Mexican again food.
I took a full blown shit.
I don't know what people used to say,
but ever since I can remember
since the mid eighties,
full blown is always been filed with age.
Look how much progress we've
made with death disease.
Not only can people live
longer with HIV virus,
you can actually now save full
blown crisis. That's a major,
that's a major movement,
you know. Um, anyways,
I got to read this whole thing. I got
to read this whole thing. It was a,
it was terrible to see, cause it's such
a beautiful frigging place. Oh Bill,
shut up with your stupid travel tips.
You, you know, go fuck yourself.
What do you want from me?
I went,
I went to three places where you go
either skiing or antiquing. All right.
There was no snow.
So what else was I supposed to do?
I went up there with Versie and I
brought some Cubans out that way.
I got to lay off this habit
I really good at. I'm,
I'm done with and not done with
it. Who's kidding who? But I,
I gotta I gotta knock it down.
All right.
I smoked enough cigars this month to,
uh,
I don't know what kill a fucking
grizzly bear. I like him, but I, um,
I'm finishing the Cubans.
I got left and then I'm
going to be done for awhile.
At least that's what I'm telling
myself. A fucking moron. All right,
let's talk NHL playoffs people.
I apologize too,
if the energy isn't what you're used
to on this podcast. Uh, like I said,
I'm in this hotel room and you remember
what happened to me in New Jersey when I
was screaming at the top of my lungs.
I'm trying to avoid that.
Trying to avoid that. Uh,
hey. You know something?
I was giving myself shit about all my
Stanley Cup picks and all of a sudden
every, all the series is other than
the turning around here, you know,
Chicago comes back and beats
the blues man. That would,
that was amazing and
devastating to watch it.
No amazing for Blackhawk fans,
but that's all they've seen
for the last few years. So,
okay.
I feel less good for them and more
bad for Saint Louis, Jesus Christ.
How many times they're
going to break your heart.
That team is aptly named the blues.
Jesus Christ. What does you,
what are you going to do?
You gotta come up with a new
name for that fucking team.
They just keep doing that to their fence.
How many times?
And they keep coming back.
Great fence.
Yeah.
Why do they keep blowing Sears?
Um,
Minnesota actually tied up to series with,
uh,
the avalanche before they
went back up three to two.
And I felt really good about it until
Matt Cook blew out somebody else's knee
once again.
Or is he calls it finishing his check.
Okay.
I saw it as a part of the night as
apology. Just talking about he has,
he has cleaned up his game.
He actually won an award for
being the most improved player,
but I just don't get stuck in
your fucking, I don't get it.
I don't get how that's finishing your
fucking chair. I don't why that the,
the reason that you would do that,
I mean,
he still could've brought his stick up
maybe and hit the guy in his shoulder or
something like that.
You don't fucking do that.
We get nothing I don't understand is
what the guy who decides to do a need in
each check.
How come both their knees don't blow out
or how come sometimes the other guy who
who's doing the dirty move like his
knee doesn't blow up. I got to tell you,
I thanks. Stefan can tell. I think he's
keeps going. A, he's going really lenient.
He only gave him a seven game suspension
and he only gave Lou Cheech a $5,000
fine for stabbing somebody
right between the balls.
I Dunno.
This guy's like a player's coach. Who the
fuck knows? Anyways, the ducks. All right,
so in Minnesota could
still win that series,
but that would make me happy because
you know what the fuck they did or mad
cooked it,
but I called the Chicago series.
Ducks are probably gone right now.
They were up three to two.
I picked the ducks in that one.
I did pick the king's over these shacks.
That one's straight it to who the
fuck knows they are the sharks,
sort of the West Coast,
St Louis Blues where they just put their,
they just taught you their fence.
They get them all excited. Hey,
we might do something. Go Fuck
Yourself. Go Watch a baseball game.
Sorry about that. Come back in
October. Yeah, this certain fence,
they just like San Diego charge offense.
It's just like,
what the fuck did they do to
deserve what that team does to them?
Every goddamn be a Philadelphia
Eagle fits. Well actually,
you know what they did?
You know what they did.
You can't feel bad for Philadelphia
Eagle Fans. You just can't, not all,
if some of them,
you can tell the ones who actually
go to the game and are human beings,
but that the core fan
base of fucking animals,
I use surprise even know what the score
is. They just hose them down every game.
That's it. Bath. Give
him eight Beth's a year,
eight home games right now of Canadians.
They wrapped their up for games to done.
The penguins are coming back.
They're three to to cut help
you if you don't like hockey.
And I picked the flyers, they actually
tied it up to two and that was three,
two ranges. So knows I still
make my pics. Might all come in.
And what would that mean, bill? I
don't know. I don't fucking know.
So now the Bruins get to play the uh,
the blue block a conch though.
I actually like the Canadians
and I liked the uniforms,
but I just can't stand their fence.
Jesus is so fucking,
there's such fucking
pussies. I just, the way,
the way they throw up their fucking hands
when they think they got robbed on a
call.
There's so God damn dramatic.
Why don't you just take a little fucking
hankie out of your front pocket and
fucking wave at, at the ref with three
of your fingers in the air. You know,
I actually went to a game that early
this year and I found they're either like
that or their absolute animals.
[inaudible] that's,
those are Canadian fence there either
the stereotypical French person minus the
Beo. I will give them that. Or they,
they look like absolute animals.
They look like they came in from some
northern fucking province. But anyways,
I'm just breaking that balls.
All right. I think this,
obviously it's a Bruins Canadian series.
Um,
I know we've swept each other in the
past, but I just think that, I know we're,
we're even enough.
Okay.
It's just never easy. It's,
it's going to go, there's,
I don't think that they could beat us
and under seven games and I don't think
that we could beat
them. And, and under six
and the sixth game would be in Montreal.
I'd skits. Got to go seven, right.
It's got to go seven when we both have
competitive teams, it goes sevens.
It's going to be a class yet,
but I'll tell you right now,
if you're not in no hockey
and you want to get into it,
why don't you check out the
Bruins? A Canadian series. Um,
all right, so, so there's
that Jesus' question.
Why do I try to do a podcast
after a fucking show? Huh?
I just want to wind down and
add to my fucking pasty belly.
That's what I want to do.
I want to go down to the hotel kiosk
and go get some fucking Oreo cookies and
then some of those nuclear orange crackers
and eat the orange crackers first.
So you get the salt going
like yeah, yeah, yeah. Right.
And then you fucking throw
the sugar down your throat.
Okay.
And you wake up the next day and your,
your teeth looked like a fucking fruit
punch thing. I Dunno what, anyways,
I haven't been boozing out here
and I'm out of sorts and um,
okay.
So now like I guess I'm
going to smoke cigars. I can,
I just fucking try and
do something healthy.
I watched this whole thing online that
creep me the fuck out about the bacteria
in your gut.
You know,
it was funny as hell actually clicked
on this thing and they got me and I
thought it was like one
of these conspiracy theory
videos, but it was actually a,
an advertisement thing because for like
the first minutes, like an Asshole,
I'm watching this and this guy's
talking about food in this country,
being the United States and he's going
just like, he's going like the video.
They don't want you to see.
And he kept going there. They,
this,
they that and all this fucking bullshit.
And he was just talking about how in
your gut you're basically, you have 80,
80% good bacteria and 20% bad bacteria.
And if you keep it at that balance,
you won't be lethargic,
you'll have energy and you'll basically
be a healthy person. And it, you know,
for the most part, they think that
that's the best balance to have,
to not get a cancer and that type of shit.
So I'm watching the shit and it talking
about probiotics foods with probiotics
like yogurt and fucking, now, what's that?
What's that fucking shit that looks
like onions, but it isn't sauerkraut.
All right. Looks like caramelized
onions and it never turned brown.
It looks like me as a caramelized onion,
right?
Sauerkraut, right? Olives, pickles,
that type of shit has probiotic sets the
good bacteria in your gut and the 20%
shit, uh, that stuff is
actually, believe it or not.
Okay.
This is really fucked up.
And when you talk about your,
your mortality,
the 20 plus 20% of the bacteria that what
they call a bad bacteria is its job is
to basically eat you when you die.
I know.
I don't know. That's what the video
said. I'm not a doctor. Don't take this.
You can do the fucking research.
So basically because the food and
our country is such fucking poison.
I guess what is happening to a lot of
people is that the 20% is getting too high
in the 80 is dropping the good versus
the bad and it reaches a tipping point
where the,
the,
the bad bacteria outweighs the good
bacteria and it starts taking over and it
starts fucking eating away at you.
Like you're dead and it can get all the
way up and do your fucking brain and you
start craving the sugars and the salts.
This sound,
why I'm talking about the stuff that I
don't know if this is true because in the
end of it,
they of course had a pill that was going
to solve all of this and God knows I
didn't go to medical school now like
you need me to tell you that shit.
You could just tell that by the
way, I try and read out loud. Right?
But anyways,
I think the core of what they were
saying was true because it sounded good.
I'll be totally honest. I didn't look
up any of this shit. So I'm like,
you know what?
Yogurt as probiotics in it.
I'll start eating yogurt like a fucking
twinkle toes there. So I'm like,
fuck it. I'm going to start. I'm going
to, what are you going to deal, bill?
I'm going to fucking, I'm going to eat
some yogurt, right? So what I wanted,
but I want to get the good yogurt.
All right.
I don't want to get the yogurt that just
says all natural or says 100% healthy
for you. I'm no trans fats and all that
shit because you know, those, those,
those big time corporate
fucking food bankers,
they've found a way to get
around all of that shit.
Basically what they did was they
got their own people in the FDA,
whatever the fuck it is,
they find loopholes where
they could, you know, they,
they draw a picture of a farm
with the sun, the sun behind it,
100% natural, organic and all that
in it isn't, you know, they're down,
they're beaten the chickens,
right.
Cutting their beaks off that big fucking
breast in the tipping over and Shit.
That's,
that's basically still what you're
reading and they can wait 100% organic and
all that crap.
They figured out a way around it.
So I'm sitting there trying to find like,
I looked up all natural yogurt. I'll do
it right now. Just bear with me here.
All right. Just the amount
of, you can't find it. I,
or at least I don't know how to find it.
I don't know how to find a reputable,
reputable, a website that I can trust. Um,
that will tell me basically
where, where, where the,
the re the thing that says 100%
organic that actually is organic.
So I just looked up organic yogurt.
Yeah.
And uh,
okay.
And this is,
this is the stony field.com.
Okay.
That's the one that comes up.
I don't know what their deal is.
So I click on these guys
like Wallaby Yogurt,
Straus,
family creamery.com.
Now that's a great name for a corporate
fucking farm is they'll call it the
Straus family creamery.
Right?
Family was fucking whacked them
buried underneath the farm.
But what killed me is like I go on these,
these websites and I click on
them and then they have like big,
like corporate fuck an advertisement in
the side. So it's just like you guys,
you guys are in bed with the devil here.
I mean maybe these guys are real.
Maybe I actually finally, this shit
looks real. No, I don't fucking know.
It's like when you go to like Edmond's
Bluebook or Edmunds and you're trying to
find the actual price of a car when you
go to buy it and then you look in the
side and like Chevrolet's paying
for advertising on there like that.
It's like a major red flag.
It's like if your underlying
every car salesman
at Chevrolet letting them know what a
fucking alumina actually costs you if they
still make that fucking thing.
The lumen guy, the Lumina, right.
Why would they advertise?
Does any of this make any sense?
Just can you guys tell me where do I go?
Where is there a website that can
actually tell me where the good food is,
where the food is.
That stats says it's organic
and actually is organic now.
Jesus did I just open up a
fucking can of worms? That one.
All these fucking people are just going
to the amount of shit that's going to be
written to me and the amount of it
that's going to have liberal or Obama,
I dunno.
You know like what the fuck.
I retweeted something the other day about
how they're trying to get rid of a lot
of the freedom of speech on the Internet.
You know the amount of racists on there.
I don't know how bad an idea
that would be sometimes,
but generally speaking they're
trying to sell it up, right?
So it's just really creepy article about
how they're going about doing it and
pushing it through
congress and all this shit.
So I retweet it because it's interesting
and I figured maybe somebody smart will
look at it and maybe they can do
something about it because I'm too fucking
stupid. So I retweeted and then
somebody writes back. Right.
So you're surprised that Obama lied.
That's what they write and it's just, I
swear to God, those kinds of comments.
I actually feel like those
people who write those a fake,
I don't believe that are actual citizens.
I think they work for the government and
they do that just to start that stupid
Republican Democrat arguing with
each other. So nothing gets done.
You know what I mean?
It's just the assumption that like,
it's like I didn't vote for the guy.
The guy doesn't control the fucking
Internet. He didn't do anything.
And the guy fucking makes 400 grand a
fucking year, mixed 400 grand a year.
He set up to be bribed.
That's why I don't vote Democrat or
Republican at that level. It's bullshit.
It's fucking over. Okay. This
is just really interesting.
This is going to happen.
I'm just trying to get it out
there and you're going to,
rather than having people read this and
if it is true and they want to change it
rather than,
than going down that road,
you're going to try to knock it off
fucking course with that bullshit. So, uh,
I don't know,
am I going to pat myself on the back
because I actually didn't take the bait
probably cause I only have 18 characters
to call this guy at con to whatever the
fuck they give you on, on
Twitter. But, um, I dunno.
Can you do me a favor?
Can somebody just for the,
for the love of God start a fucking
movement where people stop doing that
stop fucking gold is because the
Republicans forget it. Silver, right.
Your arguments over, um, any, I don't
know what I'm talking about either guys.
Right? I'm fucking wiped out
here. Uh, let's, let's do a
little bit of advertising.
Oh, Jesus. Look who's back.
It's our old friends. Yes,
you guessed it. Where the hell is
it? There it is. Our old friends,
Sherry's berries,
they came back.
Our good friends at Sherry's
berries are back. What the hell?
Holiday's coming up. Easter
already went away. Oh,
you're going to get this for your mother.
Um,
ordered giant freshly covered strawberries
from Sherry's berries starting at
1999 and over 40% savings or the,
or double the berries for just $10 more.
Click on mic and the upper right hand
corner. You just need my code. Burpee.
You are when you order.
After all,
she went through hours of labor
to push you out of her gross,
kept you alive and fed you for years.
Go to Barry's dot com and get
your mom freshly dipped berries.
This is so gross for 1999
when you enter my code Burr,
make your mom proud with the sweetness.
They're doing this on purpose. It just
this enormous, fresh, juicy mouthwatering.
Barry's white milk and dark
chocolate covered goodness.
Top with chocolate chips,
decorative swizzle or nuts. Or do
your moms some Sherry's berries today.
Go to [inaudible] dot com enter the code
[inaudible] and show your brothers and
sisters why you are a
mom's favorite child.
This deal expires Friday at midnight.
Make sure you order now.
Do you realize the amount of fucking
what does it an edible con con concept.
What the fuck is it? What's the
thing when you want to fuck your mom?
That was just too creepy. Um, anyways.
Pro Flowers bill here at pro flowers.
We get it.
You have a show to do.
You don't want to think up the content
for the advertisers. That's arch.
Is this not what?
I'm not supposed to be reading out loud.
We're on your show this week to
remind you that your fans, oh,
I guess this is supposed to
be them. Okay. I'm sorry.
We're on your show this week to remind
you and your fans that mother's Day is
next week. You reminded me
too. It's fucking April. Uh,
you got to admit the woman
who brought us into the world,
just please don't bring up her vege and
put up with all of our shenanigans is
one heck of a lady and ought to get
some special stuff. This mother's Day,
we're talking,
we're taking a guess that you gave your
mom a few gray hairs along the way.
So now's the time. Mother's Day is on
May 11th in case anyone needs a clue.
Fill her special day with one dozen
assorted colored roses with a free glass
vase from proflowers.com just for
1999 if mom has a green thumb up.
Crazy.
Okay,
sorry.
Upgrade.
I gotta stop doing this.
All right,
dude,
you guys really need to,
you'd really need to proofread some of
this stuff because it can be taken so
many different ways.
All right.
Upgrade to the pink potted rose or
yellow potter rose plant for just nine 99
more. Your listeners can get this special
mother's Day deal using your code.
Berbee you are our order
now while supplies last,
besides the longer you wait,
the price will go up.
Jesus hap happens every time.
Pro Flowers are guaranteed to last
a full week or get your money back.
The only way to get this amazing mother's
Day deal is to go to pro flowers.com.
Click on the blue microphone in the
top right hand corner and typing bird.
That's proflowers.com.
Click the blue microphone and type in bar.
This deal expires Friday at midnight.
Make sure you order them today. All right,
that's enough of that. Good Lord. Um,
maybe it wasn't, maybe it was
the, the copy before that.
That got me thinking the way I was just
thinking. That was weird. All right. Um,
let's get back to the
podcast. Oh, Ho Ho, Ho.
Geez. Um, well, 24 fucking minutes in
now, right? What does it, I taught, oh,
I gotta tell you this story.
[inaudible] um,
New Jersey's own Paul
Versey the pride of, of, uh,
what do we say to try it?
Pride of Red Bank. No,
he's too dumb to be in red
bank will say Trenton. Um,
we were working in a Portland, Oregon
and we're staying at this fucking hotel.
Right? And, uh,
there was some sort of a glee club
convention of people like 50 years,
you know, 40, 50 years old,
like they called themselves
harmony incorporated and
they were having like this
regional,
um,
they were having like this regional,
I don't know what this,
this sing off thing between
these different acapella bands,
not banned. They just sing acapella and
every year they have a different theme.
So this year was superheroes.
So there's all these old ladies and guys
walking around with Superman capes and
they're harmonizing in the fucking lobby,
right?
So me and Virginia standing
outside smoking these cigars,
right? It's fucking freezing out and shit,
but you can't smoke anywhere anymore.
So we're standing outside smoking these
things and all of a sudden we see this
guy come walking out and he's got like
a wife beater on a beer belly and these
mutton shops as jet black hair
slicked back and a big medallion.
I'm thinking he's coming, he's
an Elvis impersonator, right?
Then he comes walking out and turns
out he's like a, he's wolverine from,
uh, from x men. He
didn't have mutton chops.
It went up and around like he had died,
his beard, I guess, I don't know what,
whatever.
And he's got like fucking,
he's got this gardener glove with like
three butter knives coming out of it and
he's got this giant cigar and I'm like,
please come out here.
I got to talk to this guy.
So we'd come out there and he
tells us the whole fucking story.
And in the middle of us telling the story,
his wife is bringing the car
around and I swear to God,
I said something and I made him laugh
and he farted and he didn't address it.
Okay.
He's standing there dressed like wolverine
with these butter knives coming out
and he laughed as he was telling this
story and it wasn't just like a quick one.
It went like
sweat a good.
I thought he shit himself and he didn't
address it and he's sort of like,
at one point he just started,
he gave one swat behind his ass,
like to make it go away.
And I,
I thought he did it with his regular hand
Versie insist that he did it with his
butter knife.
And either way I eat,
he didn't address it and I
was sitting there going like,
did he just fart?
Was that version of you fart it and
I fucking looked at VRC in first.
He's looking at me,
he just had this look on his face like
this dude just farted and I had my hoodie
up cause it was cold out. I buzzed down
my head so my head was fucking cold.
So I put my hoodie up and my
hoodie up when I was smoking.
When I suffers these face,
I just turned around and would not,
I couldn't look at either one of
them and I was laughing my ass off.
And fortunately his wife pulled up
and I basically,
I left Versie by himself versus he
had to look at this guy and keep the
conversation going after this.
He basically sickly sharded right in
front of us and never addressed it.
And so first he tried to say this,
your wife pulling up with the car,
but he was laughing. It made no sense.
He just said, oh, there's your wife,
but you never laugh at that because
he just farted. He's like, oh,
there's your wife said sound like
he was laughing at his wife, like,
how fucked up she looked, but she didn't.
She was beautiful. And he was like,
all right guys, see you later. And
he waves with, this is butter knives.
And he just fucking got in the car
and drove away looking like wolf,
like a fat retired Wolverine.
Oh my God.
We fucking laughed our asses off
and we just kept imitating that far.
It's like it fucking came
around a corner. Um, anyway,
it says gross one. Are we, what are we
doing here on this fucking podcast? Let's,
um, I want, you know what? I just did
one of those city towards here in Albany.
I had my good friend Tom Lewis
come down and he filmed me.
I did a tour of this city and that's
one of these, these cities like Buffalo,
like Cleveland, like Detroit,
we use see the beautiful city.
There's just no money
here to get it going.
It's like abandoned buildings
and that type of shit.
You get a couple of blocks over. It looks
like you're in a Baltimore, you know,
another great city. It's fucking
unbelievable how that happens.
So I guess so out here though,
they're starting to make
more money because they're
working on something called a
nano something or other,
I forget what the fuck it is.
It's basically shit that they're going
to maybe start putting in food to make it
last even longer. Like preservatives
don't already make it last fucking longer.
I don't, I don't fucking know.
Either way it'll get pushed through.
People will say it's good and then
you'll try it and then some day you'll
fucking, I dunno, one
of your fetal fall off,
which is why I'm just trying
to find some fucking yogurt.
Can you just find some yoga? I
can. I get some probiotics in me.
I've watched the advertisement. They
got me, they hooked me. All right.
But I'm not buying their pill. Fuck
them. All right. I want to buy,
it's just some yogurt.
Can I just get some,
can somebody for the love of fucking God,
can somebody help me find
where the fucking food is?
That doesn't kill you. It can somebody
do that as I sit here smoking cigars.
What a fucking hypocrite. Um, all
right, let's, let's read some, uh,
some letters for this week.
Um, here we go. Plug caps.
Podcast helps me fall
asleep. Um, dear bill,
I've been a fan of yours for years.
When you play Cleveland
about six years back,
I met you and you were so personable
and you share this was me. Um,
anyways,
I had sleeping issues for years.
I discovered your Monday morning
podcast in your old podcast,
a uninformed with Joe de Rosa.
I listened to them every night and laugh
while your Boston accent and yelling
helps me fall asleep.
That, that's hilarious.
And it takes my mind off my day. I just
wanted to say thank you and keep it up.
Oh, that was from a lady that
might've been like passive aggressive.
When she's saying like, just so fucking
boring. I fall asleep. Well, uh, you know,
either that or you grew up in a household
like mine where everyone was fucking
screaming at each other. I don't
know. Oh, I forgot. I went to the, uh,
I went to the Red Sox,
take me out to the ball game.
I went to that red sox
game the day after the, uh,
the day after the pine tar incident,
which was so fucking stupid.
I mean, you know, it's funny as they
all know that they do it, and I,
I guess it's just to get a better
grip on the baseball. So, I mean,
it's cheating because they don't allow it,
but it's not really cheating.
It's actually smart. I mean,
you're thrown an object,
like close to a hundred miles an hour.
You could kill somebody
if you're having problems gripping
it because it's so fucking cold.
Uh, I mean, everybody in
baseball, same pine tar does not,
it doesn't change the
action on the ball. So, uh,
I guess that's why they
have the rosin bag,
which is just powder and powder
doesn't work in cold weather.
So everybody puts a little glob of
it somewhere. I don't fucking know.
Um,
and I gotta be honest with you,
I finally just watched the video and
everybody's like, oh my God, dude,
it was so obvious. No, it wasn't.
It was obvious after they set it
and then everybody's like, dude,
we could fucking see it
from right field now.
You couldn't what after it happened?
Um,
didn't, didn't we all cheer when Mark
Mcgwire was hitting the home runs,
we all thought it was great.
We thought he was doing sex to curls.
Then all of a sudden he gets busted or
admits to it and then everybody knew,
go fuck yourself.
I was caught up in it.
I went down there with Christmas
in my eyes. I thought him and say,
I thought if he did, I thought
no way. Sammy Sosa did.
And then once they find more,
both of them broke my heart.
Then I thought everybody did. Um,
so anyways, we went to the, uh,
we went to the red sox game and
I went down there with my mom,
took my mom to the game and had
a great time. We got pounded.
It's fucking hilarious. It was like
a, I think it was seven to nothing.
After three innings,
we'd already committed two or three hours
committed five for the game by the end
of the game.
Like some utility outfielder came
in and pitched for us and uh,
yeah, it was a shit show.
It was like a four hour,
four hour fucking game at four and five
minutes or something like that. And uh,
it was freezing cold, but
um, I didn't leave, you know,
and I learned that from my mom and I was
there with my mom so we stayed to the
end.
And um,
okay.
Was unreal.
We ended up walking out and uh,
the Bruins game was still
going because it was a,
it was an overtime. That's
right. Critical game too.
We didn't want to want let Detroit
back into the series, you know,
and tie it up to, to, to this
was to go up three to one.
And we were walking back to the car and
we walked by a bar and the Bruins game
was on in there. And I said
to my mom, hey, you want,
you want to dip in there and watch a
little bit of the Bruins? And she's like,
sure. So we walked in there, we will
literally in there for like 90 seconds.
That's all I saw the game,
the final 90 seconds in the Douggie
Hamilton came down and took the shot,
killed a tipped it in and everybody
went fucking nuts. And I gotta Tell Ya,
I really missed living
back here. Just how, uh,
sports crazy it is. And it's the teams
that I love. Like you're literally,
you're at the red sox game and out there
they, they, you know, they got the,
the old time scoreboard and they
still put the Bruins up there,
you know, instead of first stating it's
first period, second period, third period.
Then it got to the old, uh, the overtime.
And they left it there for a minute.
They like, well we don't have OT.
And somebody finally was like, well,
just put the four up there,
they'll get it. And um,
I was a fucking great time.
Hey look, an animal back here,
all the fucking places I used to
eat at when I was in my late teens,
early twenties where I could eat that
shit and still wake up with a flat stomach
as opposed to now looking like
a fucking tub of Shit, you know?
And uh,
ah fuck.
I'm driving back from Albany and I'm
going to hit another spot before I go to
the airport tomorrow.
I'm just loading up on it and then I'm
lying to myself that I'm going to eat
this fucking yogurt, this probiotic shit
and I'm going to beat down the bad guys.
I'd love to know where I'm at right now.
But those fucking things I'll
tell you right now. Booze,
if booze kills the bad
bacteria in your gut,
um, I will never decompose. How
about that? Huh? Um, anyways,
well listen,
I'm glad a my podcast helps you a fall
asleep I guess that don't tell the
advertisers that. Um,
yeah, me and Joe Rosa,
we got to get that uninformed
thing going again. He's a,
he's a big fancy guy right now.
He's been writing on the wonderful Pete
Holmes show and I think they're wrapping
their series, um, their season,
I should say this week. So
maybe me and Joe will, uh,
maybe we'll sit down and maybe we'll
crank an uninformed out. Who knows?
I don't want to keep raising up your hopes
because I keep saying that, you know,
like that fucking team that makes the
playoffs every year and then blows it in
the first round. I don't wanna be that.
I kind of have been that way though,
with the uninformed shit
though, so I apologize. Anyways.
All right, here's another
one. Bill, can I make it?
You guys remember that early 80
[inaudible] that didn't last for too long.
Making it bake it, it
teeth. We'd done a bad blah.
We stomped and
day we did there Dan.
We blab, Blab, La Bake,
baking it,
these turbid life.
I take it is a filter come people no more,
no more faking it.
I watched every episode you ever do that?
You ever watch like every episode of a
failed sit calm and when it fails you
kind of feel like you failed.
Like I'm the only idiot
that was watching this shit.
I watched hello Larry every
episode of that and I loved it.
They fucking took that off.
I watched every episode of making it
my two dads.
That's actually an interesting one.
Joanie loves Chachi. I
watched every episode of that
and they just fucking made,
it just made me feel dumb.
Then I lost all my TV watching self esteem
and I just waited until find out what
they hits were.
Then I would just bandwagon on like
cheers moonlighting in that type of shit.
Back in the day,
how awful was Bruce Willis his
haircut in fucking moonlighting?
He was doing all he could fucking do.
He was starting to lose it.
He had like the Fonzi ducktail duck tail
or the da in the back and then on top,
I don't know what the fuck he was
doing. He was poofing it up. Um,
either like a balding vampire.
Okay.
Okay. Anyways, a bill. Can I make it?
It was like a fucking disco ball
and shit in the beginning of it.
Did somebody find that?
I've actually tried to find it on youtube.
I want to say a found at one time,
but I've,
I've looked it up when
imdv I can't find it.
I know that the theme song was making it,
I think it was,
and I want to say the star of the show
actually sang the song so he would've got
fucking paid that. That's a show
Biz thing you might not know.
Show me is there,
you might not know that if you write the
song like the theme song to the show,
like you get paid every time they
fucking play it. I lost him as that.
That's why Merv Griffin, you know,
not only did he write those games,
you know, create all those game shows,
like wheel of fortune and jeopardy.
He actually wrote like,
you know when you're thinking of shit,
that Song Doodoo
Doo Doo Doo Doo
dude, that fucking thing. He wrote
that. So every time they played it,
he got paid again.
Do you think you,
you think you have enough musical ability
to come up with something like that?
Doo Doo,
Doo Doo Doo dude.
Do. How far into it could you get? We
actually good enough to come up with
du Du, Du, Du, Du, Du, du Du du Du,
right. That's, that's, that's, that's
what makes everybody, that's the hook.
Du Du, Du, Du, Du. And then you go, oh,
I remember that part from the beginning
and then you're fucking in there.
It's genius. What a giant head. That
guy had no money. We were so smart.
You know,
he must had a huge fucking brain.
I bet the bad bacteria is still
munching away on that one, Huh?
[inaudible] that's awful. Um,
can I make it? Hi there bill.
My name is Ben and I'm from
Israel. No, you're not.
There's nobody named Ben from Israel.
Hmm.
Ben's we'll visit Israel.
I thought that was like an American name.
Like Ben Franklin.
You know, sometimes I notice how dumb I
am. That was one of those moments. Sorry,
Ben from Israel.
All right.
I'm 33 years old of Florida and I've
recently decided my dream is to work in
comedy. I've written a lot
of funny bits, but sadly,
the standup scene isn't very developed
here. I'm also not a funny guy.
He put in quotes,
so I feel it might not be for me to,
uh, might not be a, I'm going
to try to correct this is not,
might not be basically my path to perform,
even though I write some funny shit.
How do you recommend I approached this,
uh,
practice the only open mic and Israel
filled with Weirdos and only once a week,
uh, get a funny actor
friend to do my material,
find amateur nights.
I don't want to waste any more time.
I want to make some sort of
career from comedy. Um, all right,
well, unfortunately, sir, you
can't rush these kinds of things.
I would do all of that. Um, but the,
the advantage that you have,
because I know you want to do this quickly
because you feel like you're 33 years
old and you've got to, you got
a kid, you gotta you gotta make,
make something happen here. Um, you're,
you're,
you're actually advanced in that you,
you understand your strengths and your
weaknesses and you're trying to see if
you can work on your weaknesses to maybe
perform or go to your strength and have
somebody else perform it for
you. I would try, um, look,
the open mic is only once a week. So
what the fuck? What does that take it?
That's one night out of the week.
All right?
The rest of the time you can
try other, you can try, um,
making youtube videos,
you can try writing scripts,
you can try all of that shit. And the
great thing about show business is a,
you just start doing it and then you're
in the business and if you don't stop,
eventually you will start making money.
If you write something that people,
that appeals to people but you never
going to know unless you do it. Um,
my biggest advice I would give you is
quit thinking about the fact that you're
33 years old and focus more on the
fact that it's a dream that you wanted,
that you know, that you
want to achieve. And, um,
you got to go after that stuff in life
or else you're going to have regret. Um,
what you don't want, you know. So I
would just, I would focus on that.
Don't quit your day job as they say. Just
keep doing that. So everything's good.
And then as you start
making more money in comedy,
eventually you transitioned over.
That's all there is to it.
So all I got to really say as graduations,
Ben, welcome to the world comedy.
Have a good fucking time and don't
be too hard on yourself. All right.
Stay away from the Kuntz
negative people and uh, you know,
I dunno, there's no comedy
scene over there so you can
create one. How about that?
They get Gulf. Jesus Christ has got to
be plenty of shit to talk about there.
All that stuff going on. Huh?
You know what she should do?
Why don't you start a fucking in
Israeli Palestinian comedy night?
You know,
you guys all hang out and get along and
then they can do a local piece going,
you know,
maybe politically leads still sides
don't get along well when it comes to
laughing.
They all speak the same language.
My name is Susie Sunquest.
Here's my cleavage and I'm standing in
front of the first comedy club and his
meal. Let's go over and talk to Ben. Ben,
how did you come up with,
did comedy with your mortal enemy? Yeah.
You know, fucking things right there.
It's wide open. It's wide open.
It's like when Vegas first starts,
they're waiting for you to
open the casino. Alright,
there you go. All right. What
do we got here? Girlfriends.
Withdrawal.
She's withdrawing dear bill Nye the
illiterate guy and you know it's funny.
That's a funny joke and I blew it because
I can't read out loud because I'm kind
of illiterate.
Dear Bill Nye the literate guy,
a big fan of your podcast.
Looking forward to others.
I'll get right to it.
My girlfriend and I have
a very active sex life.
We've been trying to say, we've
been trying to stay, sorry.
I'm still thinking of why that green
thumb made me laugh and I'm not going to
fucking tell you why. I'm a big fan of
his specials. Looking forward to others.
I'll get right to it.
My girlfriend and I have have a very
active sex life and we've been trying to
stay safe during and she
recently suggest during what?
And she recently suggested that we
withhold from sex until she obtains birth
control. Well, Jesus Christ. Yes.
My issue is that the apartment
is a month and a half away.
Oh, Jesus Christ. Dude,
fucking rub one out.
Said my bs meter is going crazy on this.
All of a sudden we can't
use a condom anymore.
Do you think this is caused from more
concern or am I just being paranoid?
Thanks in advance and go fuck
yourself. Wait a minute. Wait a minute.
That's interesting. I didn't even look
at it that way. Let me reread this. Uh,
my girlfriend,
I have a very active sex life.
We've been trying to stay
safe during this time.
She recently suggested that we withhold
from sex until she obtains birth control.
All right. And then it's a month and
a half away. My bs meters going crazy.
All of a sudden we can't use
even use a condom anymore. No,
I don't think that's cause for concern.
Okay.
What do you think?
What do you think she's doing?
Yeah.
That's not cause for
concern. That's a, you know,
you will get in the cookie and now she
took the cookies away and you're kind of
upset about it.
MMM.
I Dunno. You're a young guy,
so you want to fuck every day.
And I imagine a month and a half
seems like a million miles away.
I'm an older guy, so I'm like, yeah,
I'll give a shit joke off like twice.
I can do six weeks.
Okay.
Um, no I wouldn't, she might have.
Maybe one of her friends had an issue
and it scared the shit out of her and I
don't know what, but, um, what
I would do is I would sit down
okay.
And talk to her about it without being
accusatory. And I would just say, listen,
I just want to talk to you about, uh, the
whole birth control thing if we could.
And there's nothing women enjoy
better than that guy actually saying,
I would like to sit down and
discuss something in a relationship.
They love doing that. At least
the ones that Ma, you know,
unless they're wired like a guy and if
they get it, they're like, oh my God,
shut up and just say,
listen, you know, we've
Ben, obviously we've had a great sex
life. Yeah. And you know, I love you.
You got to do that bullshit. That's like
the beginning of a sweet chili welcome.
Everybody laggy you for copy because
this is an auditive they out here.
That's what you're doing. You know I love
you. You're beautiful. Yeah, we'll, we'll,
we'll, and then you get to the
fucking point. Just say, listen,
we had a very active sex life.
We've been using a condom,
nothing's ever happened and
all of a sudden I understand
you want to be on birth
control, which is cool. I'm just
making sure if there's no other issue.
Yeah.
MMM.
You know,
because you know,
I find you really attractive as
six weeks is a long ways away at a,
I was just wondering why we
couldn't continue to use a condom.
I'm not pressuring you.
I'm just asking
cause I really want to fuck you.
No, don't say that last part.
That's what I would do.
You Scots to sit and talk to
your bitch, motherfucker. Um,
I'm married,
I'm not dead.
Dare bill bill the beguiling.
I don't even know what that means.
You know what's funny
you guys all the time.
I'll writing in it and saying how
good I am at giving out advice.
I am the classic person that's good at
giving out advice in that I give out
great advice and then continue to walk
around and being a complete fucking idiot.
You know,
I got it.
I got everything that I just
said to that fucking guy.
I should be saying to myself,
why don't I do that?
Why don't I sit down and just say, hey,
you know, I love you and I think you'd go,
I just want to thank you for being here.
Come together as a evening
and then just be able to calmly,
I dunno, I got to get rid of this
fucking anchorman. It's, it's,
I got to get rid of this shit. You
know, I don't have to get rid of it,
but it can't be the
default fucking emotion.
Like when I was driving across from
mine and New Hampshire down to Portland,
Maine going across route to the amount
of times a mild heart attack is,
I'm flipping out about the douchebag
driving in front of me only to finally,
you know,
when it becomes two lanes,
go past them and see it's a cute little
old lady and that's why they're driving
slow. You think I would learn
the lesson like, oh, you know,
there's some old people out here, Bill,
why don't you relax the Serb country?
They do things a little slower
up here. You know, I did.
I just kept making the same mistake over
and fucking over again driving like a
maniac.
You know,
I made the decision to get off the
fucking highway. You know what happens?
You know you're going to end up behind
some pickup truck pulling a couple of
fucking horses for a good hour and
I still got mad at me. I'm an idiot.
I really have to conquer that.
If anybody knows how to fucking I go
through ebbs and flows where I'll be,
my anger issues will be way,
way better.
The end. They're still
completely unacceptable as
far as he likes to say. Um,
but then, then they start ramping up again
and it's just a fucking embarrassing.
All right. Anyways, I'm married.
I'm not dead deer build a beguiling.
What the fuck does that mean?
Look at that like right there.
What the fuck does that mean? Why
couldn't I have been like, oh,
I wonder what that means. Oh, a new
world, new word, new worlds, new word.
And this is,
this is just a wonderful opportunity
to learn something here in my own point
cans and you know, and you
know, he learned a lot.
I looked Jaycees much remain
leaking urine. Why do you,
why can I do that? Right?
But guile,
charm or enhance parentheses,
someone sometime in a deceptive way.
Okay. So this is sort of a
compliment, but not really.
Okay, here we go. Now, recently
I've been talking to a friend
that I haven't heard from
in a while via Facebook.
Oh, here we go. Uh,
we continued to talk and catch up and
I found out he is married and has a two
year old.
While that's fucking hilarious.
That should come out immediately.
All right.
While away someone,
he asked me to wait while away somewhere.
Oh,
when he was on the Internet, he asked
me to send him some sexy pictures.
See right there.
The fact that you had to,
we went back and forth a
number of times before.
He said he's married and has a
two year old. That's not a good,
that should be immediately, boom.
He's supposed to do that immediately.
I'm married. Boom. Done. All right,
so this doesn't go on a weird fucking
way because we used to fuck right.
Isn't that what's supposed to
happen? Um, and he said, I said,
I said no and responded,
aren't you married? He replied,
I'm married. I'm not dead. God.
He's also been flirting with me a lot.
I think it's disrespectful to his wife
and to ask me for something like that
when I'm sure it would,
it would help his marriage by making
her feel attractive. If he asked her
what, this was such an interesting
email. Did I read it wrong?
I think it is disrespectful to his wife
to ask me for something like that when
I'm sure it would.
I'm just gonna say what and wouldn't
help his marriage by making her feel
attractive.
I'm sure it would help his Oh,
help his marriage if he asked her
to send him some pictures. Uh, okay.
Some sexy pictures. See she said, I also
think the flirting is disrespectful. Um,
a lady, by the way. What do you think? Um,
well yeah, you're obviously
right, but I am also wanting,
why do you continue to talk to this guy?
You reached out to him. You
didn't know he was married. Okay.
He doesn't say he's married.
Yeah.
So it starts to, obviously it started to
go down, so I know. No, no, no, no, no.
And then he's, then you find out he was
married, had a two year old. All right.
So he keeps it going.
And then when he's away,
he asked you to send him
some sexy pictures and you
responded and you said No.
And you said, aren't you married? You knew
he was married. He said he was married.
Why did you keep hanging around and
now he's continuing to flirt with you.
Why are you still talking to this guy?
What's going on with you?
Yeah. Why? Why are you, why are
you continuing to talk to this guy?
This is a no brainer. Yeah.
He shouldn't be doing this.
Okay.
This is completely not what you
supposed to be doing if you are married.
All right. I'm not judging
anybody in this fucking thing.
I'm just saying that he
shouldn't be doing that.
And if you're offended by it,
you shouldn't continue to talk to the guy.
So, okay. So I guess, okay,
so wait, so he doesn't, you
don't send them the pictures,
but you continue to talk to him then
he's been flirting with you and you just
think it's disrespectful?
Uh, yeah. I mean I don't,
yeah. Yeah. It's, it's
disrespectful because
he already said the sexy pictures thing,
so it already brought
it into a bad fucking,
yeah.
This guy would bang you if
you'd let them basically.
So he already brought it into a bad area.
Um,
do I think flirting is disrespectful
online? Absolutely. If you're at work.
I mean, I don't give a shit. You
know what? I Made Jesus Christ.
We're at work.
I don't know.
It depends on the level of it, but you
know, what are you suppose to fucking do?
Like I'm not one of those guys. If
I drive down the street, okay, look,
I gotta tell you this.
When I was in la,
yeah,
I was at a stoplight by myself
and this dude jogging by,
I swear to God,
he looked like,
like marvel comics couldn't
draw a more jacked guy.
Like I looked at him and I went,
Jesus Christ,
his back was shredded.
The guy had no fat on him whatsoever
and he's jogging down the street,
no shirt on, no nothing. I mean, this guy
must be fucking everything in Hollywood.
Even. I'm sitting there going, Jesus
Christ. Now, if my wife was there, I I,
what am I going to do?
He wins.
I'll tell you right now, if I ran
down the street with my shirt off,
that would be the end of my career.
So what am I going to do?
I'm going to get mad that she's looking
at this fucking statute was God damn
Greek. God running down the
fucking street, Greek God
via Africa. You know what?
I want to go, Hey, what the fuck? I don't
give a shit. I really don't give a shit.
Okay.
I don't,
I don't know.
You don't want to talk to me when
it comes to this stipend, it's,
it's one of these,
when I look at that stuff,
like I always look at it like it
shouldn't be done. It's the Chris Rock,
but you shouldn't do it.
But I understand
it's fucking a that. That's why
the Internet, it's terrible.
It's terrible when it comes to that shit
because back in the day you wouldn't be
able to get in touch.
Tom Green has this fucking unbelievable
bid on this watch is special.
I hope he did his bid on Facebook.
He,
he does this fucking
unbelievable bid on it. Yeah.
Yeah.
Well, it's just, it's just there.
It's just fucking there. It's,
it's harder than ever. Not to fuck
around. I guess. I don't know.
But is he doing something wrong?
Yeah, but your co I don't why you,
I would ask yourself why you're still a,
you're still talking to the
person. I mean, you reached out.
That's what I'm guessing you reached out
to them because you're single right now
is what I'm guessing this was somebody
maybe you had a fling with back in the
day or a, you know, maybe
you always want it to,
when you reached out,
maybe that's what you're doing and
then all of a sudden, you know,
you find out he's married and has a kid
and then they all of a sudden he shows
that he would fuck around on his wife
and you're like, wow, this isn't,
the guy thought he was.
So you continued to do more follow up
questions just so you in your own way.
You can get this guy out of your head
because you've seen what a dirt bag is.
I got to tell you this, I'm married, I'm
not dead, is a fucking terrible line.
That's the line you say to
your guy friend in the bar,
you know,
and she fucking says blah, blah,
blah, blah. I'm like, you know,
can't believe she said that. I mean,
I'm fucking married. I'm not dead.
That's something you see to what gain.
I say that to a woman. Jesus Christ.
That's terrible.
That's just blunt force trauma of truth.
It's a one two punch. He shouldn't
have done that. All right. Whatever.
I don't know what to tell you.
I would just say stop talking to them.
Does that work? Does that work for
you? I don't fucking know. All right,
so somehow I've limped my way through
this podcast. Oh Jesus Christ.
I have more fucking advertising to re I
forgot. Hang on a second. Hi. Hang on.
Hang on. Hang on. All right, here we go.
And then I'll tell you another story.
How about that? Alright.
Hulu plus everybody.
Now you've probably tried
Hulu on your computer.
Hulu plus is so much more with Hulu.
Plus you can watch current season episodes
of your favorite shows like modern
family,
the daily show in scandal and watch every
episodes of shows like Nashville lost
and doctor who swapped with any red
slash green color coded shows listed.
Uh, you get ad free movies and
kid shows to now more than ever,
there's so much to watch.
Take total control with Hulu plus to
stream those shows and thousands more as
much as you want, wherever you want.
Hulu plus works on your computer,
your smartphone, Roku, whatever that
is. Apple TV, Xbox, playstation.
Pretty much any streaming
device you already own.
You can even watch on your phone or
iPad while on the train at work at the
dentist or in the bathroom.
You can even block off a day to binge.
You'll also get access to
originals. I'm on, I'm sorry,
Hulu originals that you can't get
anywhere else. Check out the new show.
Deadbeat a comedy about a pot
smoking guy who talks to ghosts.
Ah, Geez. I got to watch that.
That sounds a binge on all 10 episodes
starting April 9th for only seven 99 a
month. Get your shows anytime,
anywhere. That's like a quarter a day.
Everybody right now sign
up and Hulu plus.com/bill.
Click on the banner on my website and get
two weeks full access, completely free.
This is a whole extra week more with
this special offer when you sign up at
hulu.com/bill so get with it and start
streaming TV now with Hulu plus and all
one of our favorites, dollar
shave club, everybody,
nothing feels better than that first shave
with a fresh blade, right? It's smooth,
it's close and the blade is as sharp
as it's ever going to be. God dammit.
It feels fantastic,
but thanks to the shape company,
ridiculous prices. You can't afford to
get a fresh blade every week canyon,
so you dragged that damn blade,
that dull ass blade across your face
for two weeks, three weeks, 10 weeks.
Why do you keep doing that to yourself?
Maybe because the only thing more
painful than shaving with an old blade is
shelling out 30 bucks for
a pack of new ones. Well,
if you want to enjoy a
fresh blade every week,
but you don't want to take out
a second mortgage on your house,
you got to join dollar shave club.com
for just a couple bucks a month.
Dollar shape.com ships me
the highest quality blades
you can get. Um, a for Glade,
a blade guy,
and with dollar shave club,
it's only six bucks for a four pack.
I actually like two blades,
but they don't make those anymore.
At least I don't have the razor.
So I used three seriously.
Only six bucks for the best
quality blades you can get.
So every week I can pop in a fresh blade
and treat myself to an amazing shave.
It's incredible.
Um,
Dell Shave club.com gets amazing quality
blades in the mail for a couple bucks
and treat yourself to a brand
new blade every single week.
Why wouldn't you do that?
Your face is going to love your hundreds
of thousands of guys have upgraded to
shaving with dollar shave club,
dollar shave club.
I am one of them and I'm loving it now.
It's your turn. Shave time, shave money,
dollar shave club.com/burr.
That's dollar shave
club.com/burr Jesus Christ.
These fucking things get longer every
week. Uh, legal zoom, everybody.
Martin Technology's great smartphones,
iPads and other gadgets make
it easy to do so many things,
but why is it that our lives seem we
get busier at the same time? Well,
because you have to charge
all of them right now. Well,
when it comes to getting
the legal help you need,
legal zoom provides a great solution
that works with your busy schedule.
Let's face it,
the legal system is complicated.
There are better things
you can do with your time.
Thankfully legal zoom is there for you,
so if you're thinking
about starting a business,
forming an LLC or getting a trade,
Mac will or living trust,
legal zoom gets the job done right,
you get the personal attention you need
and they'll help you take care of all
the details.
Legal Zoom has been helping families and
small business owners for 14 years and
they received an a plus from
the better business bureau.
Call or visit legal zoom
today for an extra discount.
Enter Berbee you are are in
the referral box at checkout.
That's legalzoom.com
discount discount code burr
legal zoom provides legal help through
independent attorneys and self help
services.
But they are not a law firm.
Go to legalzoom.com enter the
discount code. [inaudible] all right,
there we go. All right. That was it. That
was the part count. Okay, well good. Um,
okay. I've got a youtube video of the
week. Remember I used to do that shit?
The youtube videos of the week.
Um, this is the one I got.
You guys got to look at this one,
six year old boxer.
This kid is fucking incredible.
His Dad is an amazing trainer and he
has this kid. The guy's hilarious.
He's like a, he's basically teaching
everybody else in the neighborhood.
I had a box and he's like,
well great. So now what?
They're all going to beat the shit
out of my kid. I don't think so.
So He's been training.
This kid had a box and I'm telling you,
this kid is throwing man
punches at six years of age.
He's popping the, you know those, you
know the pads that these guys put on
God help
a six year old that fucks with this kid.
They are going to be in trouble.
He's slipping punches,
he's throwing combination
and then jump it back.
All that shit that I still suck at it.
I swear to God,
this kid just wound up and
punched me in the face.
I would be in trouble if he
caught me in the perfect spot.
He probably knocked me up.
I got to you gotta see this,
this kid is absolutely adorable.
It's funny because like he's
into like six year old stuff.
Like he likes Mike Tyson.
Mike Tyson is his favorite
and he basically likes him
because Mike had a tiger
and he wants to get a tiger, like how
adorable is and you're like, oh my God,
this kid's fucking adorable. He's
missing one front tooth, cute little kid.
And then he puts on the boxing gloves.
You like, God Damn Jesus Christ,
this kid would fuck me up. So you
definitely got to check that out. And um,
I think that's it. That's gonna be the
podcast for this week. Hey, if you guys,
seriously,
I know I was fucking around,
but if you guys know any way that I can
figure out what is really organic shit
and what isn't,
because I even know if those farmer's
markets that a lot of that stuff is from
corporate farms and they just write a
bunch of horse shit on it. So you know,
you might as well just
go to the grocery store.
I don't understand why and I guess money,
why they're so hell bent on fucking
doing that to the food. But
whatever. You know, the older I get,
the harder it is for me to stay in shape.
So I got to try to make sure a plus with
all the cigar smoking in that I got to
try to do something. All right, so if you
can help me out, I would appreciate it.
Um, anyways, I'm going
to keep watching the, um,
the NHL playoffs. I know
it's hard. In the NBA verse,
he told me I was full of Shit.
He said the Memphis Grizzlies and uh,
Mama said Oklahoma. Sooners it's a
little, I watch basketball, the uh,
Oklahoma Thunder, right?
Oklahoma City Thunder,
the Tulsa turbulence, whatever. I heard
that that series is fucking amazing.
I actually really like Oklahoma.
Uh, I like Kevin Durant.
He's my favorite player in the NBA
when I actually watch all right there.
Maybe I'll put on some NBA now.
Maybe I'll watch the late game.
Who the fuck knows? That's it. That's a
podcast for this week. Go fuck yourselves.
I apologize that it took me
so long to upload this thing.
Hopefully tomorrow I can find a God damn
radio shack or some shit and I can find
the connecting wire here that I need to
upload this fucking thing. All right,
that's it. Go fuck yourselves.
We'll talk to you next week.